[Música]
787.5 millones de dólares tendrá que
pagar la cadena de noticias Fox news a
la empresa dominion systems como parte
de un acuerdo para evitar un juicio por
difamación contra la cadena de noticias
dominion acusaba a Fox de difundir
falsedades sobre sus productos tras los
resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales de 2020 en Estados Unidos
el presidente de Venezuela Nicolás
Maduro recibió en Caracas al canciller
ruso sergei labrov el encuentro giró en
torno a la cooperación bilateral y la
presencia de Rusia en América Latina y
el Caribe ampliamos desde Caracas
en Brasil el presidente Luis Ignacio
Lula da Silva convocó una reunión de
alto nivel para encontrar estrategias
para enfrentar la violencia escolar que
solo en abril ha dejado cinco fallecidos
la propuesta de un sector de reforzar
las escuelas con unidades policiales
adicionales genera polémica
Bienvenidos a esta informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos en
Estados Unidos donde la cadena
conservadora de noticias Fox llegó a un
acuerdo y pagará más de 8 de 787
millones de dólares a la empresa de
máquinas de votación dominion systems
evitando así el juicio por difamación
que podía enfrentar luego de que la
compañía acusara al medio de difundir
deliberadamente noticias falsas
impulsadas por Donald Trump sobre el
supuesto rol de sus máquinas en un
desmentido fraude electoral en los
comicios de 2020 Andrés triviño tiene
los detalles
787.5 millones de dólares es la cifra
que la cadena de televisión Fox news
deberá pagar a dominio por insistems
como parte de una cuerda alcanzado en la
corte entre las partes evitando un
juicio por difamación de alto nivel la
compañía de máquinas que hacen recuentos
de votos en las elecciones de Estados
Unidos acusó a Fox de difundir
deliberadamente información falsa sobre
el supuesto rol de sus productos en los
resultados de las elecciones de 2020 en
las que Donald Trump resultó perdedor
histórico Fox admitió haber dicho
mentiras sobre el dominio que causó un
daño enorme a mi empresa a nuestros
empleados y a los clientes a los que
servimos nada podrá compensar eso a lo
largo de este proceso hemos buscado
responsabilidad y creo que la evidencia
Sacada a la luz a través de este caso
subraya las consecuencias de difundir
mentiras los presentadores más
reconocidos de la cadena que amplia
cobertura a los infundados señalamientos
de fraude no están obligados a reconocer
al aire las mentiras pronunciadas la
suma acordada es algo menos de la mitad
de la que solicitaba inicialmente
dominion que demandó por 1600 millones
de dólares mediante un comunicado Fox
reaccionó al acuerdo asegurando que la
compañía está comprometida con mantener
los más altos estándares periodísticos
la verdad no conoce el rojo o el azul
las personas de todo el espectro
político pueden estar en desacuerdo
sobre algunos temas pero para que
nuestra democracia dure otros 250 años
debemos compartir un compromiso con los
hechos tras resolver este caso el canal
se enfrenta a otra demanda impuesta por
la empresa de sistemas para elecciones
Smart matic que le reclama 2700 millones
de dólares por haberla involucrado
también en este desmentido fraude
electoral en Nueva York al menos una
persona perdió la vida y otras cinco
resultaron heridas tras derrumbarse un
estacionamiento de cuatro pisos en el
bajo Manhattan hasta el momento se
desconocen Los motivos del colapso de la
estructura construida en 1957 los
vehículos que se encontraban en el lugar
quedaron amontonados unos sobre otros
los bomberos que realizaron las primeras
tareas de rescate tuvieron que abandonar
el edificio por temor a que los daños
estructurales provocaran otro derrumbe
el canciller ruso sergei continúa con su
gira por países de América Latina en
Caracas fue recibido por el presidente
Nicolás Maduro en el Palacio de
Miraflores Daniela Zambrano corresponsal
de France 24 en la capital venezolana
nos dio más información sobre el
encuentro
El encuentro entre el canciller Ruso y
el presidente Nicolás Maduro se registró
pasada a las nueve de la noche hora
local en el Palacio de Miraflores y duró
cerca de media hora no hubo
declaraciones a los medios de
comunicación posterior al encuentro sin
embargo trascendió que sería y le
entregó a Nicolás Maduro una carpeta con
un mensaje enviado por el presidente
ruso Vladimir Putin y le extendió una
invitación a Moscú más temprano el casi
de ruso se reunió con la vicepresidenta
delsy Rodríguez y también con el
canciller venezolano Iván Gil desde la
casa amarilla se ofrecieron
declaraciones a los medios de
comunicación dijeron que se evaluó a
fortalecer los lazos en materia
comercial energética aumentar las
interconexiones marítimas y aéreas entre
ambos países así como también aumentar
importación y exportación de alimentos
el canciller ruso sergei labrov dijo
además que la cooperación entre
Venezuela y Rusia en la práctica
fortaleza en las economías de ambos
países para sus palabras sexuales no
depender de los chantajes y los
Caprichos de occidente recordemos que
esta visita al canciller ruso a Caracas
forma parte de una gira que inició por
latinoamérica en Brasil y posteriormente
visitará Nicaragua y Cuba esto en
momentos en que Moscú Busca afianzar sus
lazos con América Latina y recibe una
condena mundial por la invasión a
Ucrania
el presidente de Brasil Luis y nació
Lula da Silva convocó a una reunión en
la que participaron gobernadores
miembros del gabinete el poder judicial
y alcaldes para referirse a la violencia
escolar que ha escalado en el último año
solamente en abril han ocurrido cuatro
casos que se cobraron la vida de cinco
personas entre estudiantes y docentes
hirieron a una docena la propuesta de un
sector de reforzar las escuelas con
unidades policiales adicionales es un
asunto que genera diferencias en Brasil
Ramiro cueva Barberena nos cuenta más
los crecientes casos de violencia
escolar que han sucedido en Brasil
generaron preocupación en el territorio
una problemática que no era habitual en
el país sudamericano pero que sólo en
este mes han sucedido cuatro casos
diferentes el presidente de Brasil ulás
Silva convocó a las autoridades de todos
los niveles para analizar La ola de
ataques de la que responsabilizó a
internet y a las compañías que hacen
culto a la violencia Armada
no vamos a convertir nuestras escuelas
en una prisión de máxima seguridad que
no tiene solución No hay dinero para eso
ni es políticamente correcto humanamente
correcto ni socialmente correcto si
Tratamos de hacer eso estamos dando una
demostración de que no servimos para
mucho porque no sabemos resolver el
verdadero problema
de agua sin embargo la propuesta que
elevaron algunos sectores sobre aumentar
la vigilancia policial en las escuelas
es un asunto que divide opiniones en
Brasil
es fundamental decir que las medidas
represivas el uso de la fuerza policial
no serán determinantes para reducir la
violencia escolar necesitamos trabajar
juntos para construir un ambiente sano y
una cultura de paz en la escuela y en el
ambiente escolar
algunas personas critican tener Guardia
municipal Armada en las escuelas creo
que hay que abordar ese tema no solo en
la ciudad de cajamar sino también en el
estado de Sao Paulo vemos que la
sociedad está enferma de alguna manera y
esto permea el tema psicológico
en la reunión participaron miembros del
gabinete del Congreso el poder judicial
gobernadores y alcaldes y se
comprometieron a terminar con esta
crisis que ya ha dejado varios muertos y
heridos fueron publicadas las
investigaciones del periodista
colombiano asesinado a Rafael Moreno
quien dio a conocer casos de corrupción
local actividades de grupos armados
ilegales y malversación de fondos en el
departamento de Córdoba en el
noroccidente del país
un consorcio internacional formado por
cerca de 30 medios de comunicación entre
los que se encuentra France 24 continuó
con sus investigaciones que se conocen
seis meses después del asesinato de
Moreno Felipe Morales periodista del
área judicial del diario El espectador
de Colombia nos explicó la función y
misión de Stories
sí por bien Stories nace con la misión
de de continuar el trabajo de
periodistas amenazados o asesinados en
el caso de Rafael es el primer caso que
llega por vía Stories en el que el
periodista llegó a contactarlos antes de
ser asesinado y él hablando con ellos en
octubre particularmente el 7 de octubre
de 2022 les dijo Yo quiero que ustedes
continúen con mis investigaciones si
algo llegara a pasarme diez once días
después el 16 de octubre lo lo Asesinan
y por eso es que por bien Stories toma
la decisión de de continuar con el
trabajo de Rafael partiendo de una
información que ella les había
compartido Entonces es una es una manera
también de decirles a los enemigos de la
libertad de expresión y a las personas
que siguen pensando que asesinar
periodistas Pues es rentable
políticamente de alguna manera que no lo
Es que desde luego las agresiones a la
prensa no acallan las denuncias y que
aquí estaremos
pues más periodistas sumándonos a a
seguir el trabajo de estos periodistas
que pueden estar solos en las regiones
pero que no están solos en su ejercicio
periodístico fin del informativo gracias
por su sintonía
[Música]